each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today we are welcoming beyond suit way
add to our group and he got his PhD in
South Korea he's currently a postdoc at
duke university has been working with
the quantum computer science I arpa
program on a team at Duke University and
his interests are in the areas of
quantum computer architecture and
previously in microprocessor
architecture so beyond Sue's is going to
today present work on quantum computer
system components for quantum augmented
cloud systems so please welcome Ginsu
and so much there's my great pleasure to
be here and these are percent for
visiting theatre it is very nice place
and I'm very proud of the Microsoft
pickers Bill Gates is one of the respect
of persons in the IT societies so this
is very good and this very honor for me
okay today I'd like to discuss all night
discuss I will talk about my previous
work in my current work late to control
applications and quantum systems so
ultimately I want to if I walk in this
world more than 10 years for the rest of
my life then I want to look at some
quantum system in the cloud systems and
then and then I'll be very happy if is
everybody can use the country computers
so let me start so my talk will consist
of three part one is my broad view of
the country club systems and second one
is my previous work and the last one is
my current work and my plan
so when I started this work when I
started quantum research from the time I
consider how can I design the quantum
cloud systems from the device rather to
the algorithm leverage so from this side
this side actually made it around five
years ago from the time i will advise on
device organo again it's my knowledge
about the quantum systems so please tell
me if I have any incorrect or if I've in
validators please just a myth so I
consider the quantum come to system
consists of these hierarchies so after
all aware we can make contemn device
like a qubit gate operations based on
the physical device like ion trap
optical a superconductor and mr or
solid-state or whatever so although we
have a quantum device like this one but
if you don't have any point competition
model then we cannot do that we cannot
make a contrecoup systems so so so we
usually have a three this is my
classifications so we have a three
models like a soft based model and
measurement based model and now we have
other one like any on base models so
sake base model is very similar to
conventional sakya based conventional
classical come to models so we just make
a circuit and we just run the socket the
next one is measurement based models so
we if you prepare large number of APR
peers and we can do measurement among
them then we came to the conditions so
this is what we call this as measured
with base model another one's recently
based on the anyone's we can make a
quantum teach models so these three
things i think d three things are major
competition model in the country
comforter but there is another one like
a diabetic and also maybe we can propose
the one another one based on cellular to
motor so so I I believe they're there
are so many borders but typically we
have a three models like occupy smaller
bedroom with bass player and any models
so now we have a device now we have a
complete motors but this is not enough
because
this quantum device battery sensitivity
to the errors so we have to apply at
operation code or foreign schemes so we
have to use some photons previous like a
concatenation code or topological code
word sup is code so this layer
technically for the air crucial part in
for torn us apart so the three day where
device model and equations makes or
makes can bags one scale over and filter
on the computer models but that's not
enough to make a punter computers
because we still needed some components
like a like a derp or free transform
which prior these kind things in
combinational terminology we call these
a database telemeters so we have to make
those counting's and also we have to
make a memory systems or cpu or both
systems were maybe we have to add
another one like a communication
components so based on these we can make
distributed when worked in other systems
also now I I do not believe that we can
make a one holistic on big systems one
controlled on big quantum systems we
have to make an Internet communication
system between the nodes I think that's
a practical way how to make it a
contactor system right now so we have to
consider this distributed way so up to
this level we can make what one working
want to come to system but that's not
enough way sir so we have to build up we
have to make on other arrays like a
system software primitives like a
compiler scheduler or optimizer and
other things so I call this one content
content head systems so these rebels
these hierarchy of the rebels base
quantum come to systems were we can make
a connection between the computer so we
can put some some compounds here for the
communication part so based on these
hierarchy and the structures we can make
up control systems now the next one is
applications
so I'm considering this hadees
architecture this is a cloud accounting
systems so currently right now in the
classical domain they also do a lot of
work on the cloud committee systems but
at the same time we have to consider how
to use that how to continue how to use
the control system for the for the cloud
systems so i made this level of
component ease the warning todo lawyer
is application primitives like hyper
booms contain allergens and second one
is hi Sakura predictions and the last
one is high-speed communication
primitives so these kind of primitives
can be used for making applications in
the in the conversation across systems
days code uses our application as a
service so based on these primitives we
can build up some applications like your
competition science engineering
applications were healthcare or
transportation and what evers but for
that we have to have one middle layers
like application primal layers so this
framework have to map these applications
primitives to the applications so in
this case in this case we have to we
have to combine the classical cloud
systems and control of systems and the
last one is a test the device where the
user interfaces like me individual cases
and the like company like Microsoft or
other companies division sectors and one
other one international sectors usually
we probably we have to use quantum
system fortunately we have to consider
the National of wreckage enforce
probably like national security or
national energy energy partners but
sometimes rather we will use this one
for the PD sectors like a bank or
Microsoft or Google or effort systems
but for finally we like me i also want
to use quantum systems through my
telephone
okay so this might be this my big
picture of the quantum algorithm called
systems so deep a teacher's assistant
aware this is closed system rabbit and
this is andy and user or the toddler
where the world that i'm bae systems so
so as you can see this is not a big job
art is not a small job this very big
jobs we have to consider political
integrations of all areas from the
device driver to the objection layers so
the impactor of this device I mean that
the property of this physical device
will affect all things also the
application will affect the device as
well yes one who composes
distribute through okay then you
security programs the right yes that's
true
they were progressing
Oh somebody have to do that maybe I
cannot do this but somebody have to do
that so we also relate or likewise that
can problems for them for if I if you
have to make a global onto network
systems how can manage the security from
the attack from like North Korea well
from other countries so those can
security issue is very important also in
the cloud assistant commercial
cross-system the most big problem music
securities so we have to consider same
things the quantum cases where but
luckily we have or some some high secure
system like you Katie systems so maybe
we can support much more higher security
compared to connect classical systems so
in for me
I want to have something contribute to
security too
secure way to exchange beats one to him
more secure than anything else
yeah I think what's missing from during
yours countess rephrase is there's no
quantum information backbone here in a
cloud where you can take advantage of
the fact that you can send entangled
States you can send superpositions and
you can send cryptographically secure
messaging throughout the data center or
even across data centers yeah and that
also needs to be on your bus besides
conventional distributed processing
quantum distributed processing yes part
of hybrid so this part this earlier have
to consider that one's network system is
what exactly okay so this is this is my
dream to make these whole system's my
life so late this before come here i
have woken some part especially
operation part n the system part related
to application part i do some work like
Krypton ceased in Washington in part and
the system part i do some work on the
architecture part and our restaurant
again the code parties so today I try to
discuss I tried to tell you about this
previous work and also my future work
applications this is my previous work
where am I join this world by myself and
of myself also want to know that whether
it is really use for this is a literally
have approved for information processing
suppo dad I I do some work to analyze
the quantum search algorithms so at a
time I worked on the processor chosen
path of such problems project search it
defined as searching problems but not to
find the target element but to find the
blog address of the target element so
this is the orbit partial problem these
are big problems compared to original
group approval such problems but in this
case because we put some relax on the
problems so we have to ask some high
such as property compared to
compared to Gruber algorithms crew both
problems so with other people's we found
that one way how to do that but the idea
is passing through we can define the
three bases one is target state and dad
the second one is other state in the
target lock and the other state the
other the other races for the DL estate
in a non-target blogs so based on these
three bases we can find this on faith
connexion to achieve the success Prosser
t'en such a private is very high the
next one is we try to extend this
problem for the more general cases like
a group of Williams we also consider the
multiple target cases multiple target
blockages this is three beer so we found
some some way how to do that I don't
want to tell the or details but I just
want to say that what I did after that I
try to move to find some real well some
more practical problems but theories or
even artificials we are given one player
potions and we are also given to 80s but
we don't know which way it is a real
rate for the given function like implant
functions okay the problem is we have to
define we have to decided which one is
correct one so for that for that we
propose one algorithms but the idea is
also synthesis from step one to came as
two steps we apply the conventional
Gruber algorithms but from k minus 2 K
minus 1 to K steps we are frightened if
we apply some modified accrual
priorities lenders some conditions so
this is I volumes so as you can see from
the from from jealous from one step to
came as two steps we apply the
conventional operators but from what
Porter k minus one step and K steps we
apply different slightly different could
operate a patient of phase conditions
that I want to set a to these are the
phase condition face conditions but the
idea is like this one so if you because
we are given to wages
wait is full of 1 billion functions we
can put these two weights at the initial
state on the blocks appears like that
way so in this case we assume another
condition the weight the vellum function
is symmetric so the summation of a 208
is to be wait 1 and wait to should be 1
so that a location in the blacks appear
should is symmetric symmetric means if
if this one is going down then this one
should be going hi so like like over
this X what it is XY plane this should
be symmetric like that way so so this is
a trajectory on the blocks appear for
the last two steps how can how can you
do that so so in the algorithms this is
a famous one steps groove operator this
is K steps on operators as you can see
we apply the conventional impose on with
a target state like pie angles but the
next stop textin version have to be
chained based on these settlers so grew
operated as you know it group approach
consists of two emotions in motion over
the solution state and an inversion
allowed over the initial state so we
just need to change the angle for the
emboss on over the interstate so this
this target will show that so this if
this is if it freezes are some state
after came as two steps and we apply the
inversion of the solution state so that
this state have to be here but next to
inversion impose on over the initial
state this deck symbols a text to
inversion have to be change based on set
angle setter in in the previous slide
these values okay so so we found that
the anger based on this based on these
conditions okay in the trajectory based
on these settlers we have to rotate this
state into somewhere here yes
what is the way how do you assign
weights to me I'll wait well our rate is
defined as a ratio of the number of
solutions over the number of interspace
if there's only one solutions so little
means just some input shows that up
there's one satisfy this ya number we
set is fine so the fraction of subscribe
assignment yeah it's correct so you know
no ahead of life the weights not know we
are given to the two edges but we don't
know which one is correct for that's a
promise we are given the bond trailer'
pollutions we are given to wait yeah
promise problems but we don't know which
one is correct one so these are going is
for dead cases
so so during this work we found that one
way how to do that how to distinguish
this the right one and the next one
needs to generalizations in the previous
case we assume that the weight of these
two the symmetric that means the
summation with these 28 is one but now
we make some locations so in this case
we do not have such conditions so the
summation of 28 can be from 0 to 2 this
user is meta cases but the idea is
tricky and the idea is very simple so we
just we just make we just make a larger
input space by adding some cubed so that
we can reduce this problem to the
symmetric cases so this is so this is a
way so we can make on other functions
based in the initial functions from the
photo initial input space from 0 to n we
use the same functions a from and 2 to n
we use we use the similar functions but
so did actually see same functions but
from 20 to 30 m plus L we assume that
the Apple should be one and from for the
other input space from 2m plus L 2 for n
we assume that the output is 0 so this f
prime function is derived from the F
function f but the weight is different
so because of this case because of this
dispersion of the solution space we can
make w on fri and ww2 prime and the
automation can be one and that the
condition for l is derived like that way
so this is this very trigger and this is
very simple ideas so the one thing I
want to emphasize that the necessary
cubed usually 2 cubed is enough even
though problem is seems to be very
general compared to previous cases but
two qubit is sufficient
and that's the general next to extension
is to the case for multiple realities in
this case we have em and wages and we
want to choose realty decided which one
is correct one the idea is to apply the
sequencer or repetition of the applying
the a smeltery case algorithms like that
one so if you are given we are given
these am Number waiters from MW want to
WM now we want to we want to know that
which one is quite fun so we choose
candidates to can't it from the ass the
one is minimum and one is maximum and
the way of flight is motivated stern
algorithms the previous one you need the
promise that one of them is correct yeah
but it may be either
Maxine is the real that's right so in
this case that we have a promise one of
them is right as arrived at it but in
this case the tools reach us a tooth
that sometimes we choose w.1 r WM part
unfortunately w1 and w2 WM is not the
correct one then this this alga version
shows it for give us some candidate
likelihood wages at the correct one
based on there we can choose it but even
in that case we can say that not choose
we're not selected weight is not a
candidate so we can destroy it we can we
can we can even audit okay so this is
nug out systems so every repetition we
just now got one by one but if sometimes
if sometime later if one of them is a
right one quite 1 then that weight can
be choose and that way it can be
survived the whole remaining are
iterations so we can choose that right
one so this is one way how to do that so
finally I actually do not we did not
consider any more generality of this
problem so our last job is to prove that
whether it is an optimal one out so we
try that we try to prove that whether it
is optimal or not so for that we apply
the quantum Corey complexity messages
going to query on in this method so we
are we employed we exploit the imbalance
quantum adversely methode so he proposed
wondering how to do that so if you can
find some relation R and we can find it
some some color some input space x and y
and if you can find that these kind of
conditions then we know that there are
amazed this number of Korus are required
to do the completions so we applied the
same idea for our case
what is the very sore sorry you can't
clearly squeeze to what our pirate coin
is selected number and with what does
all of them do our Oracle's f yeah
option yeah in quantum algorithms
usually is yeah F F can be implemented
by your records so I mean digital sapori
but sucky complexities so how many core
is how many Oracle function is called
acquired for doing the disillusions so
based on this information we can infer
whether this algorithms optimal one out
so we just applied the same ideas in our
case so we in our for our problem we
found that these values from em to add
from the reaches of lighted same
algorithms so if you can prove that our
algorithm is optimized so these whole
things
quiet
case what case a number of number of
tests and above steps means number of
groove operators how many good work
reporter have to be used for doing these
abortions so cutting where is easier to
move you didn't return it to its source
a pretty you posed a question with
whether you are very is optimal yeah i
mean our version requires k steps for
the i work for the problems and based on
these audiences we found that k steps
are you part so so this one this whole
things are actually for my understanding
of the point of contention power for the
some algorithms but luckily this kind of
problem can be used for machine learning
right now so I'm extending this idea for
machine many cases but from now I'm
trying to explain that my previous work
on the system part so to to build up the
quantum systems we have to consider many
things but in that case we cannot do
anything so I just consider that some
simple cases like other circuit first
based on this I can get some menus itís
about the depth row bond and the
scheduling and at all sizes and the
robot as well so I choose the other for
my primitive primitive for the research
of things so my first question on the
system part is what is the death row
bound for the addition on the 2d
architectures the question is this
actress is very important in this cases
because this one to the NTC prob channel
means we allow just the nearest neighbor
interactions between the qubit and we
allow jazz the two cubed gate operations
as a maximum and we allow the concurrent
to cater Persians on the average cubed
and we allow justice off channels for
moving the qubit bit in the neighbor our
enemies nearest neighbor
and team team is t means to GV 880
persons we allow single cubic a
depression and the turkey VK depressions
the same is concurrent operations so my
question is in this in this sack later
to the NTC with the sub channels what is
the depth rebound on the additions for
the additions so for that i exploit the
graph theory approaches in the graph
theory we know that some some graph
invading our issues like this cases this
is guest graph and this is host graph
and the our job is to map this gas graph
into the host graph because if the host
graph has some limitation like this one
then the growth and the guest graph have
to be changed after the change means
from edge like this one have to be the
distance of this edge have to be changed
like this one so this is one cases of
the graphene lettings so this this case
graph these are three and this one is a
line graph so these ads from node 1 to 5
have to be changed like this one so in
this case there is no direct as from
node 1 to 5 if they want to communicate
they have to use no to so that means
this this interaction distance have to
be increased in these graphs okay so we
just use this idea in our case so we we
found that there's some some vector like
a dilation the dilation is defined as a
ratio of the diameter of the host graph
and the diameter of the cats crafts
diameter is a diameter is the maximum
distance between any two nodes in G that
means in this case diameter is from from
node 1 to 2 from load from this node to
this node maximum this vacuum distance
of that any two
to notice okay so what you call me
bathing is not really amazing it's just
mapping actually met yeah nothing
backing start em in your serum is about
to embedding it the next day yeah this
theorem about doing bathing free formula
to yeah yeah so this this dilation
dilation value implies the increase or
the overhead of the edge the increase of
the distance for the guest graph okay
based on this dilation effect we know
that infra we we can infer how much how
much oh boy they have to be ad for the
distance of the every edges host Grove
in order yeah that's correct that's
correct so so locally in the addition
circuit the addition in the graph story
addition can be done can be implemented
by the tree graph okay and and then and
that is to the NTC can be represented as
a just a greedy structure so in in graph
theory terms the problem is like this
one so we want to embed complete graph
structures into to DeGraaf structures
then how much directions so that's okay
so based on that we've we found that
this is a lower bound low amount of the
depths depths in this case that means
from this set from this leaf node to the
tabloid because addition is tested from
the dis lift in order to the tunnels so
based on this I wrote based on this
property we can form that there is a
lower bound like these barriers so so if
we are given KD entity arc later then
row bound is this one so for the 20
cases the depth row bond is square root
of n
so so we found that the next question is
then what about the tips optimal adder
the 2d our teachers so we propose one
either based on the based on the
partitioning of the input qubit like
that way so we put the other like it
like this way so the number of the
number would column is routine and every
column contains due to n elementals so
there's n cubed and we and the remap the
quantum additional socket on this
architecture like that way so this is a
first phase in the first phase the first
column have to do the conventional
ripple carry additions but the other
columns the other columns they do not do
that because they are they are input
carry is not a defined it yet so they
just do carried rural portions ok the
next step because of you we found that
the carrier alpha for the first columns
so based on these carry out food we can
we can propagate this carry into every
columns so every file every column can
know that what's the input carry for
each columns the next step is to do
justly placated itions for the every
columns so three steps like that one so
this is what first phase and the socket
so this is first columns for the first
phase and this is our other columns from
too-too-roo to n columns they are doing
this they are doing just the carrier
griddle portions and this is our key for
the carry propagation pit in the columns
and this one is for addition for the for
the love from the column tool to root n
columns they are doing just elliptical
additions based on the input carries so
so this is one example for the 94 cases
so as you can see the depth is just a
Lutron Pickers occurs
the time for this edition is returned
and this Kelly profession requires
routine times and this edition also
requires root n times so depth is
returns so this is our one design which
is optimal and we compared with that
this is this is really good compared to
one DNT crd traders so we analyze that
whether these two the NTC shows that
better performance in terms of K 2 K 2 K
and Q means number would al cubit and
number of Gator portions so this this is
a value when the when the this to the
entity other shows that shows that
better performance compared to one DNT
say one DNT see others equal teases
improve on so from from the n is 3 this
act this error shows that better
performance but this one is that one the
CD km is very good so so unless 51 this
other shows a better performance
compared to our one but but larger than
the 51 our a letter is better than one
so now by the way right now in these
days we consider KQ very important
because depends on the k2 values we have
to decide our Croatian rappers and the
device error requirement so nowadays
cage effect is very important so this is
0 this is AC means arbitrary absolute
actually this absurd concurrent rock
scissor abstract means they do not care
about the distance so they allow any
combination of the qubit operations with
regardless of the distance so this is
our kind of theoretical boundaries of
the additions so yeah that those kind of
works on my previous work on the system
part but from now I'm trying to tell you
about my current work
the system part so recently the quantal
come to a researcher walk is heavily
focus on the research part because we
already know how to make a photon to
control systems but the problem is the
recess is too too big for example if you
want to do show volumes for the two
thousand two thousand bit then we need
maybe we need 10 to the journey tribute
with the tentative 30k depressions but
technically this is impossible actually
I'm working under some some experimental
papers they sometimes when i say i need
the 10 to 20 cute and they say oh you
are just idiot because they say our best
is to make it as a 3 cubed so there's
very big head actually so our job right
now is to reduce we have to reduce
research overhead as much as possible
and also we have a sump open symmetric
like a DCR this is for algorithm rabbit
so how many areas how much earlier and
how much delay and how much repetition
of the algorithms are required for 2
into y autumn's so our job is to reduce
ADC i consider on recess or wed so we
have to reduce the research over and
also we have to reduce these Eddie's
here so this is my understanding of the
list under single go overhead over the
break down from divergent lever to the
device level so the algorithm designers
they just make us some rinds stabilized
but we can make we can program using the
sea or using the F sharp or using the
scapular languages whatever so this is a
resource overhead in the cases several
rounds were 100 grimes that's enough but
while you're flying the compiling we
have to decompose this source code in
terms of reversal socket so that we have
to add the additional overhead
thisis comes from that this is these are
since this is Miss old but that's not
all we have to do again for the single
cubic 80 portions especially like
arbitrary rotation are arbitrary angle
rotation kato caters so we have to take
composer again so this is the additional
word for these single gb gate operations
but that's not all as well so we have to
add other ones are the radius for the
education part and for torrents apart
and also we have to consider
architecture constraint so this kind of
discount this kind of things increase
the research over it as well but it's
not all as well so we have to do again
the flattening of the some pot so like
that way Hercule we have to add or
resolve it step by step until two until
to generate most encode rivers what's in
code so our job is to reduce this
horrible by optimizing every rivet but
my focus on right now is to these two
levers are clear apart okay so my
approach is to optimize some components
like an asthmatic part and also improved
is oxygen apart and then the necessary
systems of tears and also try to exploit
some code composer method first one is
our ultimate part even though we have
all other papers we have all our double
it works on the architecture I
management part while still it is not
sufficient because most of previous work
focus on depths were size work a tease
they do not consider usually area until
a composite of the air or delay or days
not consider error crashing parties so
we right now we have to consider these
factors so my so the maybe the immediate
goal is to find it some 82 RK to optimal
others on the to delay out but probably
probably we just need to revise
the previous designs like that ways so
I'm considering right now this way so if
you if you can put some powder if you
can put some boss boss for the
communication channels then maybe we can
reduce the delay for the completion part
but we because this boss is not everyone
so we have to increase that the resource
over the like area but if if we can put
very if you can put this boss very well
then we can make the smaller KQ we can
make we can make a very good other which
contain which has a very small at uk2
values so this is one way the next one
this is justice right this is just
working diagrams the next one is I think
it is much more practical important
conventionally we assume their app to
abrogate operations we have to apply our
questions right but if he considers the
CR or a priority of the algorithms then
maybe we don't need to do that maybe we
just put finger Eric Russians for one
part if the value of a DCR is very small
compared to a flying error correction
for every cases then may then we have to
choose that way because our main poppins
lettering is not not just for other
property but a this year so we may file
we may we may find some some past number
of their questions and the day or
locations in the in that circuit so that
we may be we have to increase the area
until I but we may decrease error rate
so we can make we can find some
trade-off between the number of number
will our questions and a DCI values so
for example so for example
we can put air question only for this
part well only for this part not all of
them but we don't know yet which for
which how many other questions is
required and what is the location for
them and also we can consider other part
other recent component like a multiplier
or even more even more we can make
another ultimate component like a 40
point representation asthmatic or a
colleague coding is very useful with a
classical hyper most competing devices
so we make we can make fronting codec
arithmetic circuit the next one is
architecture part and this is my main
area right now so so let me tell you I
say that we have to optimize the ADC are
but how can you evaluate ADC are so so
technically we have to have some tool
set to evaluate this a and T and C i but
but these tools that have to also have
to focus on oxygen apart Alkazar
constraint or and also air crashing part
so this this activity research or
accessory consideration is very
important to George that which are
questions what kind of parameters have
to be considered so in our teams I mean
without the team members we have focus
on how to how to make how to build up
the good educator and the necessary out
and scheduling algorithms and how to
evaluate the whole inputs so our target
axis right now is to the antici
architecture but the communication
channel is going to be different
previously we consider swap dinners but
we right now will consider constant time
condition chatters buy or fly or by
using simultaneous in swapping
actually DS from it is based on the loss
and bound with the mouse papers and also
based on the measurement based motors so
we can we can apply the simultaneous
income sloughing that means we can
prepare
PR pair among any distance R cubed at
the same two at the single x so we can
implement concerns time communicating
channels by using this way so so by
using this one we can we can do remote
to see not get in any component errs and
we can do teleportation in a single x so
so based on these architectures I was
always started so our job is to make a
one architecture which is pride this
kind of communication channel and
consider this kind of active constraint
so to make a teacher from the from the
from the empty space it is quite hard so
we checked that assembly code because
this assembly code is an input with
architecture part so this is one sample
code from the another team members in
our in our project so they give us one
also very cold and a disassembly code
consists of some modules like we call
this 11 0 katie's so this this is
component lift Regent one radical gate
or one gate operations for the
components like just prepare paper
preparation of g status jello state
actually and this one is for measurement
at the g basis but this is primitive and
also we can define the scene operations
so these things are elementary component
for building the whole algorithms so
this is the decision index set borders
the top Holy One to poly one consists of
calling the lower level modules in this
case low-level motive means this
leverage achates ok so this is the block
diagrams of the hierarchies so this
topic one calls some seen as several
times because of this code like way like
this way we can make a hierarchy of the
modules of to Tom neighbors so these are
terminator
some never main motives many model
consists of several sub modules like
this one and each cell phone calls on
our soil motors so we found that there
is a hierarchy like that way and we
found that there is a modular Moodle of
ways so based on these inside we propose
one way how to make our teachers so our
idea is very simple we have to make a
modular approaches we have to follow the
higher ocular approaches so this is this
is our ideas if you can make the arcade
if we can make a schedule and if you can
make a rail for model one and if would
it be try to call this model one then we
just map these input parameters to this
model 1 by using some some some way
after some way means a short balls so we
can ray out all modules like that way
and then if you can and we can schedule
this mappings by using some some
additional resources and then and then
and then we can we can we can make all
infidel go geum's like this way so so
for these architecture we define some
some primitive primitive component like
a boss so these balls implement in terms
of shoppings simultaneous income
shoppings so this component they can do
so they can take and support in terms of
utilities to neighbors so we can make we
can we can implement in terms of a from
this port to this port at the same time
so that means by using these boss we can
make some information channels from from
this part to this part also yeah
it's like yep so this is a secret so you
have a hierarchy yeah modules yeah which
means you cannot recover so did you
consider secrecy allowing in the quantum
algorithms we usually do not allow is a
psych a cyclic pro because continuity
that's one floor from the beginning to
end that's all that's logical that's a
logical you're now trying to compile
fizzle and so if I have a module that
you used a hundred times I'm really
looping on that module passing in a
state vector a1 and getting it up asset
backing I really are moving yeah so you
do get recursion probably like this one
right so sometimes here sometimes here
sometimes here then you have to use the
same orders because not because if I
mean just a negative 0 so the way I read
if you go back to your further slide the
way I read the approach is you take an
algorithm you figure out the common
modules yeah up to a certain level of
abstraction yeah so you start your the
very bottom here you may dutifully as
you may go higher than that you may say
I have a QFT I have an adder I have
whatever you implement some number of
those in the hardware yeah then you have
a scheduler that decides Oh in parallel
I can run these verses these have to go
see questions they only have so many qf
tease yeah for example so i can only run
this one and then this one has to wake
up yeah and so what you're doing is
doing a layout not of the algorithm but
the module is the algorithm needs and
then your scheduling the algorithm on
top of that that's real that correct
that's correct okay so that's it XO
daddies are active sort of a scheduling
be good maybe I can skip some stratus so
by using this one and by using this one
we can make a parameter passings so this
is 1 this is what you are saying so this
movie won't try to call this motor tree
and this motor to also try to call this
mood ur3 but sometimes they may be
sometimes they try to access the same
odors
but the oxidizer I mean high-level
schedule have to control these kind of
scat is kind of conflict so that is a
job of the high-level scheduling and
also like it likely the previous
questions if your model won't try to
call this mudra story several times then
the high-level scheduler have to do that
I mean they just need to map they just
need to met the input qubit to somewhere
here and that because we already found
that scheduling and Ray out of the
Buddha tree so we don't need to worry
about this part we just passed the
matter which was passed input parameters
to some place here free defined phrase
here then we just use same schedule that
means that means this is advantage of
this kind of approaches if we have a
schedule of the role models and if the
highliber scheduler can schedule for the
mapping of the input wrapping the
parameters then we don't need to worry
about the loadable part during the
dealing that so telling the hide-a-bed
scheduling ok we as well as a single
game for insight for your face
transformation with reset I need AC not
in one place that's going and after you
will do it ok that's a typo commits a
compartir i call this is repaired I
called dad with low-level scheduling
this is just for Hydra part I just saw
assume that this is encapsulated motors
but as you manage all that we have to
decompose again so this is a very big
view the top view of the architectures
so we can put this boss somewhere here
oh but by the way we don't know which
way is the best way to locate it to this
post but we have idea like that ways so
we can put a boss like that way and we
these blue own use modules and one other
entities this is a magic state factory
so this magistrate factory can
distribute vegetated any place in a
constant time if there's no computers ok
so this is very I think this varied very
very mean this can this can support very
cost-effective way
this is a hard review and the next one
is loaded with you rural oxygen and
robin scheduling so we have to decompose
these modules is the same very similar
way so the maybe they'll I bet very
naive idea is to put want one or
complete way like all combination all
all channels for the all combinations
but this is but this is I think this is
too Peter so we have to use some some
resource efficient way so we have to put
some posts like that one and then the
key problem is we have the partition
this circuit well we have the parties on
the group of the qubit in the photons so
these shared posts have to be used it
for all four combinations if this module
won't communicate the other modules some
orders then these spots have to use and
also this won't have to have to be
communicated with the other two modules
so this partitioning have to consider
the connectivity or sensitivity of the
crab of the socket so these shadbolts
have to be located on the very sparse
were very low connectivity component or
low connectivity parties not another
highly connected apart so technically
this part contains this this part has
very high connectivity compared to these
connections okay so we have to we have
the partition the input socket based on
these conditions and then we have to put
the boss so that these finger boss can
support all come our combination of the
communications is a lot more
sophisticated I would assume then what
people think of as a bus cuz it's costly
generating to your pairs shipping
everywhere fourth teleportation for the
zealots so if you're saving can do so
also we have a very strong argument of
our daddy issues so at the physical
level we have to do that like a
reputation prepare a generation and
deceleration of blood and other things
but from after level zero at the
physical level we can assume that we can
apply the logical a bear what's kims why
is there with them because if you guess
wrong but the wrong pair settle in
places that's going to cause a latency
yeah that you wouldn't have had yeah if
you didn't have to get that yeah okay
that's two there's a reason why I put
like that way it depends on the pandal
is we have to increase even though it is
a protocol one but sometimes we have to
make a very very thick process but we
don't know yet I mean which which way
which way this is good so can't we just
adopt now we just device conceptual way
so this is one examples we consider one
module like this way so this is just a
and writings that you can see that
there's a there's a location of the post
ideas for these bombs but but we were so
I think we also have to consider the ad
CL dimmers so even though this case the
graduate the number was is very well I
think very hard at bed Raj so we have to
we have to reduce some number of bosses
based on the ADC optimal criterias but
we don't know yet we don't know where
means we do not have any tools right now
but really we are considering that
conditions so this is a whole view of
the arcata part this is Tom my review
I'm in high review so we can map the
algorithms into these poems based on the
modules and the based on the hierarchy
and the each component in the later part
can be decomposed like that way and also
this one can be taken back that way so
this one this one is what you are what
is your questions
so we have to build up some physical
world level zero components like a coral
out of repeaters we have to use these
elementary ties to make up to make up to
make a boss well communication channels
but luckily in our project this is not
arbitrary so detail I people they do
that they implement this rollable minute
level one scheduling for for
implementing level to level one
component is so they are they are
introduced a physical labor socket and
physical level compounders and they
propose a generator level one component
like a level 1 cor loft or repeaters
from that we can filled up yeah I have
to say that at the physical level we
have to consider this relation protocol
we have to consider Lapita protocol many
things but this forever we don't need
stood lifetimes yeah so sending the pair
does mean you have it for more than a
certain period of time for you to send
begin even if you didn't use it yeah so
I didn't show yet I didn't show this
right but we we have a very very
important occasions the location of the
repeaters even though we assume that we
have we need these lands boss but we
don't know the good location of the
repeater how many in the locations that
question is also one of those our
questions and based on that did unless
it's just simpler because we know that
how to do it how to rate how to schedule
the energies adjusted to make us some
programs so that's for my des Pollock
set apart or from from now I want to
talk about cod come buttons so we can
imagine these cases come to system a use
one code like a sting code contains SMB
use other code like a stink like a big
record because the religions they have
to communicate I mean this is natural in
the closet systems our air crash in
court sorry our question cool very
different color spaces yeah so to make
it to make a connection between the
computers we have to consider these
problems why would you have to
I mean I don't know I did it why can you
go what if somebody wrote a library
using a specific code I'm you're off in
another library using a different code
you want to use their flaws you have to
convert between your coded for under
their code in the classical sense on a
quantum machine it's a whole question of
whether we actually be important where
we care that I guess that's what I right
right wait it's an interesting question
how practical is different question
that's quite so up to now we have a tool
messages one is the code teleportation
Messer and another one is that
stabilizer seconds mess call the
teleportation means if you prepare
encoding the EPI pair from fitting the
code a new collection called a and a
decryption code B then we can do
adjusted teleportations so so this is
this is called code teleportation sorry
you can do what teleportation is perfect
and the stabilizer sequence methode
means we can find some sequence of
stable stabilizer gate operations for
one in critical state to the target
status but in this case we have to check
we have to find the sequence okay so
it's really awesome for making some
programs subject programs how to find it
so technically we have a true method
like teleportation methode and the
stability sequence method this work is a
little bit related to like a stated
composing research work but this one is
just for based on the practical it's
based on a terrible are you like a
teleportations maybe we can propose
another method but I don't know I tried
several times but I'd I cannot find it
anywhere maybe we have we can find on
other ones so ladies I'm considering
some technical cases like these cases
this one is a thin coat and this one is
bacon
cases how can we make one specific
preset socket for doing the code
teleportations so this knowledge also
that how to prepare epr state including
eps state for the code a in this case
it's teen code and refer could it be in
this case potential code so i found that
this circuit is work in walks factory so
we can we need to prepare the cat state
and we apply these H gatos transpose
away and the way of Lila see not this
part and that part these all things r
transpose ax and the results measure the
some part of the k-state and the other
positive the Cal State and then we just
check the parties based on this party we
just saw fly there including the xk8
operations the DC just like just like
compensations to make an API pair
between this one and deadness this is
one socket how did you send one code to
another no this is just for preparing
the epr pair for called a and could it
be and the weekend we can do tell
application by using this epi pair but
pairs are in different college spacious
yes this one this one is from the code a
yeah this one is called could be and
this one test eight no I understand
Catholic what I understand is Cote may
have a different number of qubits than
could be yeah we're example so how does
this teleport from one to the other no
no no it's easy so he's preparing is
pretty good and EPO this is just the
prime shell k may have to see how you're
going to use it so let let's stop okay
this gives you now a fully entangle
between the two and they have some sort
of base they agree on basically at this
point yeah okay you're at that point
fine yeah
and this is wondering how to do how to
make a photon skin for this circuit so
we can we can prepare this platypus
state for the code a and logical process
for the code P and we can prepare this
cassette Protonotary and this is
transporter so we don't need to worry
about that and then because of this this
one makes some errors I mean some some
hair here there are errors so we have to
apply 3 time we have to do three times
for measurable things so answer every
every mmm every job we have to do
quantumatic Russians with a for the pre
pure Buddha for their questions so that
at the end we have to apply their ex
katie's so this is one a how to do that
but this is just one cases so now we
consider some application of these cases
this idea for reduction of Lisa so bored
put some Gators speciality Gators in our
calculation the D gate on the bay
control requires a lot of changes a lot
of cubed because bqueensho cool
equanimity gate is basically based on
the latest exhibition protocols so so we
do some pretty mean work if we can if we
can change or if you can come come boat
pacon show included the state into Rida
Miller include state and if you apply
the leader below including 2t gate and
then then we can be covered again into
the pee control code they control equal
estate but but the issue is the ticket
on the reed-muller code is transpose
okay so so some tea gate can be live
laced by the transverse ticket on the
different code
so thin code to the gate and the take
control to gate is non Transposer but
redeemable code ticket is transporter so
if the cost for the code conversion is
small then we can lift relays bacon
shorty gate in to redeem your ticket
operations okay that's the main idea so
this is our predators but this is not
correct one and this is not precise one
so our love calculations show that for
the steam case stinking cases if we
implement a ticket on the sting code we
need this amount of resources but if we
avoided a code conversion and the if we
lift racist in T into lead mlot gate
then we need this amount of research in
this case this is not good but in the
bacon show called as I told you very
control code requires a lot of
discretion are aboard so that we can
replace this amount of religious or
bored into small on so if we if you use
the lead immunity gate then we just need
this amount of religious over it this is
the original or conventional a
commercial commercial case of this is
over it even though even if we assume
that the fidelity of the dredge estates
is very high like one we indicate the
resource all over this very big but if
but but if we if we can use it
readability gate we can reduce this or
this resource over into this our values
but we can more we can go further
because thing called t gate is much more
simpler so we can replace again into
dust Cynthia gates so conclusion of this
rod is if we can if the cost for code
conversion from one color to another one
it's more smaller than that are some
gate I could take it then we can we can
lift less it you can live with the
complexity get into
yep and where's the official I me on
these codes that's Russian for these
codes somewhere you've done my spy on
the top one at some of these air rate
numbers don't make sense because you're
above threshold you can't correct oh
yeah so doing the only numbers that
would make sense of the ones that are
below you know that individual oh yeah
probably yeah this policy below yeah and
then it looks like even using these
conversion things the top one is still
better right yeah if you look at the
single code model the resources are
always smaller at the below thresher
that you see up on top is never beat by
anybody else I mean you'd never used the
bacon short code in that scenario is
even down at the bottom it's 2,800 2600
games yeah yeah so technically and
physically we have to consider this
area's this founders and this one is we
don't need to worry about this part
right and there's no better it seems
like it's too expensive yeah right and
that's before the cost of the code
conversion yeah so this one did stero
royalties general it either cases over
and this one is figure it is one so this
is this is ideal case hostess even the
case the code counter can show that
other entities
I'm curious you have the same numbers
for the single code model for reading
their code yeah what do you know they
look like so so it looks like 930 to is
the best thing you have here for the
steam code you know this the same number
would be for real our code right because
I mean you can do team transversely me
Mulder and you can do I mean basically
you mesa commercial computation grants
personally no visible code that does not
allow hk2 H as a transporter well if
you're careful you actually can't so I
just combined the advantage of with
other coders this thing called an
invitation code has other entity on the
educating and clip with aggregate
Katie's as a transporter but the
reed-muller code shows the advanced you
on the ticket only the alligator like H
gate it was not allowed transpose so I
just combined the advantage of that
and also this is a I think this is a
more practical Asians we have to
consider cause commotion on the rig it
about the pits are usually used for
communication part and then we Peter
have to consider a portion as well so
liquid I have to consider could
compulsions in near picture so that's
all my current consideration on that
system part and also I also consider
some some some issues on the application
part so just one extension of the my
previous work I want to know that is
there a quantum algorithms for the
ledger leigh-on-sea and man annuity
checking of the preamp functions these
two prima trees is very important on the
city or security part because brilliant
function is user user for symmetric key
symmetric key systems so they won't know
that they want to know they want to
check this resiliency and non annuity as
quickly as possible but but up to now
there's no critical critical efficient
way to check these legend see and
non-linearity so now idea is whether the
counter computer can have them to check
these legitimacy and nonlinearities
efficiently but I am working without
another fellow but we still found it
some just not good i mean it's not good
ladka means is not like super super
polynomials feel it's just a result
solve polynomial speedo is possible and
also i want to know that was Corey and
Sark impressive for these problems that
means I want to know that was a
limitation of the quanta competition on
that problems and also we can expand
this problem into a post content creator
p domain and the second one is machine
earnings so pickers brain function can
be used for cryptography and also full
of machine learning so i'm considering
to use this irosian for machine learning
but I'm just starting I don't have any
ideas ultimately we maybe we can make a
point on bing much more
you frontin being such algorithms but
that's all so currently i'm working on
these issues are in the octa career I'm
refining the low-level and high-level
architecture and a day of scheduling
Andrea legumes and this analysis method
an hour is most part we are trying to
find some best way to put the air
cushion and the locations and the code
combustion case we try to check the
fault tolerance level of the output
circuit and also is used for the oxygen
part the crepe terraces and motion
earnings so this this one shows up my
currently research target a literal
level resource reduction is my main goal
by using the arithmetic and co-driver
optimizations and also comparable result
magicians if the alex is here so i'm
considering to use high-level
optimization method into oxygen apart so
like about the optimizations that's it
thanks so much
so kind of question so you mentioned you
okay so you have some concatenated code
scheme basically what you normally do is
error correction followed by the coda
gave Paul Bear correction opportunity
and you mentioned that you could
optimize potentially by eliminating some
error correction steps in systemotics
place like that when you have a strategy
for how you might go about doing
figuring out how to do that what one of
us is to consider the graph theory as
well so in the crepes or you can find
that the weakest or the consistent note
congestion load means this node effect
or other graph graph edges or and notice
so this is very important note yeah
spread yeah so baby we can use that
approaches for the discretion travel the
outages are extremely expensive so think
of the size of the of the unit you want
to look at classical processing is very
hard to figure that out in the general
case you can solve if you have to do is
reach Graaff generator but maybe we can
use it even though it that cases because
we just need to optimize some component
so just we just need one this is stared
block yeah you're going to do some
specific add or multiply or QFT yes
that's the scale but to hide maybe we
don't know you have give me intuition or
how much you might save by doing such a
thing
in a factor you get I mean I suppose
that would depend on what module you're
trying to optimize right yeah so
resently there's one papers already
shown in the history source they
consider the hop they are tightening how
we have to enter questions every time
some skeptics ok that's a tighter so
they also consider these probably offers
on it once gaba they what they find
there is they just look at the sequence
actually because of decomposition they
look at HT h or HD you our favorite
sequences and they just basically show
analytically that the maximum you can go
typically is two or three things
obviously quite soft so that's first yet
but they're so that's the lowest level
sequin right they just consider that
sequence okay so it's just single Single
Double cubed 713 code yeah and they just
say that okay if I don't era correct
after the H so they look at thht of
different permutations in this and say
if I don't era correct after the agent I
just I've ever cracked up for HT what
happens to my
and they give a table of it essentially
they say I mean to me it means maybe you
say back up to I see in the Canadian so
they're not exactly went for single
logical cubic foot worship ginger which
I would imagine and the other work that
I know of that looked at that was out of
cookie cookie screen and they look at it
is slightly different fashion they just
consider that the error correction
tiling kind of how often they apply
errors into a short code they try to
optimize lab and I think the fudge was
much larger than justified for two they
actually simulate it I mean parts of it
parts the test some of the locals fine i
think it was higher like i don't want to
say that three years later doesn't that
look it wasn't that big though we're
talking to me n factor in our factory I
presents a like a factory I don't know
100 or so this is an order of magnitude
plus oh really if I really in that but
they make a lot of assumptions okay but
you're not going to gauge the same error
in the same place you know with a
certain and on and on yeah that's right
if all the all the world is working for
you while your faults are going on yeah
when you're alright last question on
that related topics I mean do you
haven't do you think that that kind of
same thing could be applied to
topological codes so certain
tix
honestly we because of this code is not
our part in our project we did consider
but probably I think in the subjects
code we can make a graph based on the
rotation based on the Brady operations
so maybe we can make a graph structures
same ways so the distance in this case a
distance because we I think we can put
the tip act as a node in the graph Lisa
detect the dose kiss code and at the
distance for the freedom to see no
questions we can make a long-distance
edges so maybe we maybe we can consider
those kind of information as I like a
weight of the edges so in this case we
do not consider weight of the edges I
mean what kind of improvements we have
to do it as a weight but in that case
maybe we can put some distance as as a
distance distance as a wait for the
graph then maybe you can use the same
algorithms I mean that key I yeah right
but I think part of the problem here is
that were only in these experiments or
simulations people are just again d
Flores and noise and that people were
from austin and John
this morning which basically shows now
these Lika chairs are the fuge problem
in the cert infecting kids and the way
they propose I mean that I didn't read
the whole paper yet but I did read the
extraction conclusion basically it seems
that you have to measure these cubit
actually want to move to maybe a full
measurement closer states can instead be
given the 3ds be given the earlier
assumptions before that paper right I
mean also did a bunch of work in terms
of given the lengths you know between
the defects right how long you could
wait before fixing things for your
matching went that on right I mean it
was a time yeah but there was there was
a time delay depending on the day that
you could wedding yeah but I think he's
assuming he uses a new era correction to
have every yeah but Chuck doing it on
every time step that's the point are you
don't decode every chance it right yeah
Oh even without the coach Oh doesn't
help okay but this new paper says
they're basically the leakages them this
so that is that is the main thing to get
what people started to do non unitary
noise they're realizing oh my god that's
what's going to kill us more they thing
else yeah so I don't know okay so sorry
for the extended question home I can
we're comin on the adder circuit at work
when you did this square root of n you
assume there's no change in the width
for that embedding
because if you add more cubits you can
do it in constant time so constant up
so you must make an assumption well he
had the same note with cubits is he was
adding yeah right he never would bear
did I been right you do the proof you
actually had no additional student yes
that data door is not optimal that's a
lot like that yeah so that's just like
try to show that the conceptual way how
to change the previous edit by using the
policy skims the body means week we can
reduce a delay from root n 21 ok but as
you know that this the one column
requires that Cal flow so this requires
root n times so this is not optimal one
but i just want to show that this is
just one way how to put the boss on the
adult socket it's not for showing the
optimal one but maybe we can we can use
i mean if you have our access horrible
scheduler and ray or tools and we just
need to use these tools for other
circuit also it can be the input for
this scheduler then we can forget it the
Ray out of the others
any other questions
thanks so much